i can't imagine
a greater
compliment in this
or perhaps even
quite as important
to anyone who's travelled in the
antarctic
the name is bass british antarctic
survey
are magical letters
you could rely upon bass to do this and
to do that
and that this ship
is following in that tradition
as we've hearing
science is of increasing
importance
and it was science in the antarctic
which warns the world
of the hole in the ozone layer
back in 1985
british scientists were closely involved
in that revelation
the remarkable thing
when considering that
is to remember
that it only took two
years
for the world to take notice
of the warning
that the hole in the ozone layer was
damaging the entire globe
for the nations of the world
to take action
and that
saved the world
from major damage
coming from the skies
and it was but it was only two years
after that
in montreal
that that agreement was reached
we all know now
the
magnitude of the
dangers that are facing us in the
immediate future
would it not be marvelous to suppose
that as a consequence of our discoveries
and that science is discovered
that the nations of the world
joined together
and actually did something
at cop in this coming conference let us
see what it does
but i hope and pray that my goodness it
takes action
that the nations of the world in the
light of the scientific discoveries that
this ship
will undoubtedly be making
that nations got together and listened
to the silence
of what has to be done
if the world is not to be overcome
by catastrophe
i
am indeed
a very proud man
to be standing in this remarkable vessel
to be associated in any way with bass
the british
antarctic
servant
may i wish this ship
and all who sail in her
and all the scientists who research on
board
bon voyage on its forthcoming voyage
to the antarctic
i know
that the findings made on this ship
in the next few years will be of the
greatest value and importance
to the welfare
of the world
that is little to the science
[Applause]
you